THE IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT'S NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. CURRY ARAMBULA.
BARRICADE HAND. BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERON. CARRILLO
CERVANTES JUNE. CHOI COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY.
DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON. GRAY GRAYSON HANEY
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA. KILEY BLACKY LEE LEVINE.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI
THIS AREA WHEN. DONALD PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUOTE QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH. STONE
TAKING BELLA THERE AS OPPOSED TO
A VOEPEL WALDRON. REWARD WEBER.
WICKS WILSON. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
FOR ALL OF LIKE THE MAPLE YES
WALDRON AND MRS ME WALK THE WALK
RUSSIAN THIS IS YOUR ONLY
SELLING SIMILAR PRONUNCIATION.
AND THIS IS. OUR E. Q. PICKING.
OKAY GARCIA THAT'S WHAT I WAS
THINKING. CHECHNYANS WHICH I
DON'T KNOW TO CHANGE THE CNC
YEAH HELLO. AND THOSE WHO. HOW
WE CORREA COREA OKAY OKAY KAMALA
PRACTICES WOULD DECIDE TO MEMORY
IN MY HEAD I GUESS IT MAKES
SENSE OF THIS IS LIKE SHARKS.
MEMBERS QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER SO HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO OFFER- ADDITIONAL
SONG AND PRAYER- THIS WOULD BE A
SERRANO BIGHORN SHEEP SONG. IN
THE WORDS IT SHOW HERE'S FIVE
BOB AND I HAVE A BOT. IS SEARCH
IS THE BIG MACHINE THE NIGHT
ABOUT SEARCHING BOB AND I HAVE A
- LATER WE HAVE A RESOLUTION-
THERE WILL BE MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS FLOOR. TO RECOGNIZE A
CRISIS IS GOING ON HAS BEEN
GOING ON- WITHIN INDIAN COUNTRY
OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS PERSONS INDIGENOUS
WOMEN. AND SO THIS SONG THAT I'M
GONNA SAYING THAT SEARCHING FOR
THE BIGHORN SHEEP. IS ALSO-
SEARCHING FOR A MISSING PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL MISSING FROM
INDIAN COUNTRY THAT ARE OUT
THERE. NOW THIS ONE A THANK THE
LEADERSHIP FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SING THE SONGS HERE ON THIS
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. AND THE SONGS
ARE ANCIENT SONGS THAT WERE
NEVER SUNG ON THIS FLOOR BUT
BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSITY THAT WE
HAVE WITHIN THIS LEGISLATURE IN
OUR LEADERSHIP WE'RE ABLE NOW TO
SING THE SONGS SO THE VOICES
THAT YOU HEAR IN THE SONGS THAT
WE'RE SINGING OUR VOICES THAT
ARE NOT PRESENT ON THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. BOMPTON I'VE OFTEN FILED-
THEY'RE NOT A LOT BOMBER THEN
I'VE OPTIONS I AM. BOMPTON A
BOMB. BOMB BOMB OF ALL FILES.
THE NEW. BIOME BOMB I'VE ALL-
BOMPTON OF OCT AW THEN I'VE ALL
. FILE LAW THE NIGHT OF OCT
VOMIT THE NIGHT OF OCT. FILE.
THEN THE LAW FILE LAW I HAVE
LONG- THEN THE- FILE. GOD AW-
LAW THE NIGHT OF OCT BOMB THE
NIGHT OF OCT. BYE LAW THEN-
TONIGHT WALTON WHILE- THE NOT.
FILE LAW HI MOM FILE. THE NEW.
HI MOM. AB A HIGH HELP UP BY THE
NIGHT OF A.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST
. WE ASK OUR GUESTS TO REMAIN
STANDING AS WE JOIN IN THE PLOT
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THESE IN THE MINUTES OF A M. B.
R. O. KELLY SAY ARE CLOSE TO ME
MEMBERS SIXTY SEVEN THIS
PRESIDING CHIEF FORTUNE PROGRAM
THE BEST IT WILL REDUCE REYES
MOVES AND MISS DAVEY SECONDS AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL WILL BE DISPENSED
WITH. PRESENTATIONS AND
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS WILL BE
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING ON TO MOST. AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MISS
REYES. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
LOW KALRA HOLDEN AND RUBIO TO
SPEAK ON ANDADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS THEY HAVE
A PHOTOGRAPHER AND GUESTS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. PERCENT
TO SOMEBODY PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB
TWO SIX NINE NINE FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER TO THE SECOND READING FILE
THE BILL IS NOT FISCAL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE TO HEAR
THE FOLLOWING BILLS UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION TODAY IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE CHOI AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN THE WHAT THE GARCIA
AND AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY GREAT.
WITHOUT SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE OUR NEWEST
COLLEAGUE WITH US TODAY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATT HANEY FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTEEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK FOR BRIEF REMARKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ARE FOR YOUR WARM
WELCOME- MY SEATMATE JUST TOLD
ME THAT I DIDN'T OATH OF OFFICE
WHILE I WAS DOING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE HOPE THAT. THAT TELLS
YOU THAT THE LAST COUPLE DAYS
HAVE BEEN A BIT OF A WHIRLWIND-
BUT THE THAT SUPPORT AND THE
WELCOMING AND THE KINDNESS THAT
YOU ALL HAVE GIVEN. I AS I'VE
TRANSITION TO THIS ROLE HAVE
BEEN TREMENDOUS I COME TO YOU
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I WANT TO
THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE MY
COUNTERPART FROM FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM.
OUR DISTRICT- MY DISTRICT LIKE
ALL OF YOURS IS EXPERIENCING
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES- THAT ARE
SHARED ACROSS OUR STATE. AROUND
HOMELESSNESS AROUND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY OF THE DRUG
EPIDEMIC. I THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH EACH AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU I TO
CONFRONT THESE CHALLENGES- WE
ARE STILL REELING FROM KOBE. AND
ITS IMPACTS AND OUR WORK IN
FRONT OF US I COULD NOT BE MORE
IMPORTANT. SO I COME HERE WITH A
LOT OF HUMILITY I WAS A FELLOW
MANY YEARS AGO TEN YEARS ELECT
THIS IN SAN FRANCISCO. BUT I
KNOW I HAVE SO MUCH TO LEARN AND
THERE'S SO MUCH WORK TO DO- I
ALSO WANTED TO SAY THAT. THIS
WEEK ESPECIALLY OUR WORK AROUND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM I COULD NOT
BE MORE IMPORTANT IN AND YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT I TO JOIN ALL
OF YOU IN THAT FIGHT AS WELL.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I LOOK
FORWARD TO MEETING ALL OF YOU
AND WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU- AND
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE. A
HUMBLING HONOR I AND WITH GREAT
GRATITUDE TO THE PEOPLE OF MY
DISTRICT FOR ELECTING ME I TO BE
HERE TO SERVE WITH YOU ALL. I TO
TAKE ON THESE MOST IMPORTANT
CHALLENGES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU AND
WELCOME MISTER HANEY MEMBERS WE
HAVE GUESTS VISITING WITH US
TODAY JOINING US IN THE GALLERY
OUR GUESTSFROM THE GIRLS ON THE
RUN PROGRAM. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WELCOME.
ADDITIONALLY IN THE GALLERY OUR
GUESTS FROM THE UC DAVIS REDWOOD
STEM EXCELLENCE THROUGH EQUITY
AND DIVERSITY SCHOLARS PROGRAM
ALONG WITH THEIR PROGRAM MENTOR
CASSIE GRAYSON CASSIE IS THE
DAUGHTER OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON WELCOME. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY ARE MEMBERS OF THE
LICENSED PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
FROM MEXICO PILOT PROGRAM
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY. AND
FINALLY MOTHER'S DAY IS THIS
SUNDAY I WOULD LIKE TO WISH ALL
MOTHERS IN PARENTING PEOPLE
HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH SIXTY THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL. SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
NINE TWENTY NINE TWELVE TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX TWENTY FOUR
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE OH THREE
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE SIXTY TWO NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR FORTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY. FORTY SAID.
BERMAN TWENTY TWO SEVENTY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS TWENTY SIX TWENTY
FIVE OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY MINUTES. TWENTY SEVEN IT
WITH A MEMBERS 250-529-5716
441-734-1760 EIGHT. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE NINETEEN TO BEFORE
201-521-2920 ONE FORTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO SIXTEEN. POINT TWO THIRTY
SIX TWENTY TWO SIXTY NINE TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE ELEVEN TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN ELEVEN.
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FIVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWENTY
NINE SIXTY SIX SEVENTEEN ELEVEN.
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR TWENTY FIFTY TWENTY SIXTY
TWENTY NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE
NINETY FOUR. 254-025-5120 SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
TWENTY SIXTY THREE TWENTY NINETY
FOUR TWENTY NINE SIXTEEN. TWENTY
NINE THIRTY NINE AM TO SOME
LEGAL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE.
WITHIN MINUTES. ALL BILLS WILL
BE DEEMED READ. ALL AMENDMENTS
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. FOR
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS UNDER
CONSIDERATION SHALL BE CONTINUED
. MEMBERS WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE SHALL MOVE
ON TO THE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN ACR ONE THIRTY SIX
MISTER RAMOS. FOR THE FIRST
ASSEMBLY READING. THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS RELATIVE TO MISSION
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE AWARENESS MONTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER US YOUR RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
FOR- SUPPORTING ACR ONE THIRTY
SIX I RISE TO REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL AND THEY'LL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SIGN ON AS CO
AUTHORS- A TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
REPORT BY THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE STATES. NEARLY HALF
OF ALL NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN 46%
HAVE EXPERIENCED SOME TYPE OF
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE OR STALKING BY
AN INTIMATE PARTNER ONE IN THREE
INDIAN WOMEN WILL AT SOME POINT
IN HER LIFE EXPERIENCE THE
VIOLENCE. OF TRAUMA. ON SOME
RESERVATIONS NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN ARE MURDERED AT A RATE
MORE THAN TEN TIMES THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED CASES OF MURDERED
AND MISSING INDIGENOUS WOMEN AND
GIRLS WILL REPORT IT TO THE
NATIONAL CRIME CENTER. WE ALSO
KNOW THESE CASES ARE UNDER
REPRESENTATIVE. AND
MISCLASSIFIED IN MANY CASES. TWO
YEARS AGO WITH YOUR HELP WE
SUCCESSFULLY AUTHORED AB THIRTY
NINETY NINE WHICH AUTHORIZES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO WORK WITH
TRIBAL AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO IMPROVE DATA
COLLECTION AND IMPROVE
COLLABORATION AND TO BRING
AWARENESS AROUND THIS CRISIS
THAT HAS PLAGUED INDIAN COUNTRY
FOR MANY YEARS. BUT NOW HAS
RISEN TO THE LEVEL OF ADVOCACY
AND MOVEMENT- AND RESOURCES
THROUGH OUR BODY HERE IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. WE ALSO HAD A
HEARING- YESTERDAY ON THIS TOPIC
. WHERE IT CAME OUT THAT ONE OF
THE SPEAKERS IDENTIFIED THAT
THEY'VE LOST OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE IN THE TOWN
OF ONE THOUSAND IN THE TOWN OF
POLO. TO COVERT NINETEEN DRUG
OVERDOSES IN THE DISAPPEARANCE
AND MURDER OF NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. THESE ISSUES CONTINUE TO
PLAGUE INDIAN COUNTRY THESE
ISSUES. DEMAND OUR OUR RESOURCES
AND OUR ATTENTION TO BRING
RESOLVE TO THESE ISSUES THAT ARE
STILL HAPPENING IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I AM
HEARTENED THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR RECENTLY
ESTABLISHED THE MISSING AND
MURDERED UNIT WITHIN THE BUREAU
OF INDIAN AFFAIRS OFFICE OF
JUSTICE SERVICES. THAT WILL ADD
WEIGHT AND NEW ENERGY TO THE
INVESTIGATION TO RESOLVING THESE
CASES IT'S ALSO A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR US TO TAKE
UP A START TO COLLABORATE WITH
INDIAN LEADERS AND TRIBAL
LEADERS ON FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DISCUSSING. AND MOVING FORWARD
ON ALERT SYSTEM WHEN MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS PERSONS
INDIGENOUS WOMEN GO MISSING I
THINK THIS BODY COULD RISE TO
THAT LEVEL AND START THAT
DISCUSSION MOVING FORWARD. THESE
ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT STILL
PLAGUE ALL PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SAFETY FOR ALL LET'S REMEMBER
THAT THAT ALSO INCLUDES
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN NATIONS. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I ASKED
FOR THE ROLE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROMMEL'S.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED IT WOULD ASK. I THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO
VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR ACR
ONE THIRTY SIX AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY DEEPEST GRATITUDE TO
OUR COLLEAGUE IN OUR FRIEND FROM
HIGHLAND. FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION. CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES AS A WHOLE
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE AHORRIFIC
HISTORY WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES. REFLECTION
IN AWARENESS ARE CRITICAL ABOUT
WE MUST FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND A
BETTER FUTURE THROUGH OUR
COLLECTIVE ACTIONS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR OF ACR ONE THIRTY SIX AND
OTHERS ON THE FLOOR DIFFER.
ENSURE THAT WE PUT TO SUPPORT
OUR STATE INDIGENOUS
RESPECTFULLY ASK NAY VOTE MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MYSTERY LESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON YOU'RE
A STAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IT
I'VE GOT ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
HERE TODAY. THE HISTORY THAT WE
HAVE TOWARDS OUR INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE AS WE ALL KNOW IT'S
HORRIBLE. THIS RESOLUTION GIVES
US THE OPPORTUNITY. TO ACTUALLY
TAKE ACTION WHICH WAS MENTIONED
TOO OFTEN WE TALK ABOUT.
SOMETIMES WE HEAR PUBLICATION.
WHAT WE NEED TO SHOW. OUR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
HERE THAT WE SUPPORT THEM AND WE
ARE READY TO HELP. PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS TODAY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A R. ONE
THIRTY SIX WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS CONTINUING
ADVOCACY HERE FOR THE WORK THAT
HE'S DONE IN HIS THIS SPACE TO
CONTINUE TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE. AND HOPEFULLY BRING
SOME JUSTICE IN OUR STATE SO
OURS ARE VERY STRONG AYE VOTE ON
ACR ONE THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DETAILS
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST TO MAKE CLOSE.
WHEN A THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR THE- THE SPEAKERS THAT SPOKE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL NOW
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL TO
SHOW ONCE AND FOR ALL THAT THE
VOICES OF THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
ARE NOT GOING SILENT THAT THIS
BODY DOES HEAR THAT VOICE AND
STANCE WHOLEHEARTEDLY TO SUPPORT
THESE RESOURCES AND A BRING HOME
OUR MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN. ACID THE FIRST
A ROLL BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS
. MEMBERS MISTER ROBERTS HAS
ASKED THAT THE FIRST ROLL CALL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
ONE THIRTY SIX. THE CLERK WILL
NOW OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
YOU DESIRE TO VOTES. MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FIFTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS
. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL NOW
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NO. THE EYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS NOW TO MARK THE
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE AWARENESS MONTH WE HAVE
TRIBAL CHAIRS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER THE MEMBERS WHO WERE
PREVIOUSLY SELECTED TO BE IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MAY MOVE TO
THE BACK NOW. EVERYONE ELSE
PLEASE REMAIN SEATED FOR THE
DURATION OF THE CEREMONY. TO OUR
ESTEEMED GUESTS AS YOUR NAME IS
RED PLEASE COME TO THE REAR
CENTER FILE TO BE RECOGNIZED.
THE CLERK WILL READ. OUR FIRST
ANDREAS ROBERT SMITH CHAIRPERSON
PALA BAND OF MISSION INDIANS.
MEMBERS MEMBERS RISE IN
RECOGNITION.
SECOND HONOREE IS REGINA KUMAR
CHAIRPERSON SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND
OF MIWOK INDIANS.
I THIRD HONOREE IS JOE JAMES
CHAIRPERSON THE YUROK TRIBE HE
IS UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY. I
FORGOT TO REASSERT DARK DUSKY
CHAIRPERSON I OWN BAND OF MIWOK
INDIANS.
OUR FIFTH HONOREES JANET K. BILL
CHAIRPERSON PICAYUNE RANCHERIA
OF THE CHANCE THE INDIANS.
OUR SIX ON A REAL ISSUE SINCE
TARANGO CHAIRPERSON WILTON
RANCHERIA.
SEVEN AND FINAL ANDREAS THOMAS
TORTOISE CHAIRPERSON TO MARTINEZ
DESERT CAHUILLA INDIANS.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS HAS ADDITIONAL
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY IN
RECOGNITION OF MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
AWARENESS MONTH PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING OUR SPECIAL GAS.
MEMBERS THAT INCLUDES THE
ASSEMBLY OBSERVANCE OF THE
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES AWARENESS MONTH.
YOUR WITHOUT. MEMBERS WILL MOVE
ON TO THE THIRD READING FILE
ASSEMBLY BILLS WE'LL BEGIN ITH
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE. FOR THE
INTAKE FOR TAKING FLOOR
AMENDMENTS AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
AMERICAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARA
QUE HANNAH THAT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU US APOLOGIES THE COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX
WITH THE PAYMENTS BY THE REPAIR
CARE. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE TO PRESENT AMEND MY ON AB
SIXTEEN SIX WE ARE ADDING
URGENCY TO THE BILL AS ALL OF
YOU SAW THIS IT APPEARS TO BE A
MATTER OF TIME BEFORE ROE V.
WADE WILL BE OVERTURNED THIS
BILL WOULD THAT WE HAVE
PROTECTIONS FOR PROVIDERS.
PATIENTS AND THOSE WHO ASSIST IN
THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING A CARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FROM THE
FOREIGN STATES LAWS THAT ARE
HOSTILE TO ABORTION AND WILL
INCREASE OF A LIABILITY ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WERE DOING SUCH
IMPORTANT WORK TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE ACCESS TO SAFE
ABORTION. IN ADDITION THIS BILL
THE AMENDMENTS THAT INITIAL
COOPER'S THE BILL I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE STANDING WITH ME IN THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT FIGHT FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER HAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES HERE
RECOGNIZE AT YOUR DESK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE ASK A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON AMENDMENTS. MISTER HAS
ASKED FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE THIS
AMENDMENT. SEEING AND HEARING
FURTHER DISCUSSION. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN ROLE. ALL THOSE VOTE
TO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTES IS TO VOTE. QUICO
CLOSER ROLE AND THE VOTES. I
FORTY FIVE KNOWS. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. SORRY I FORTY FIVE
NO TEN I HAVE IT.
THE MOVIE ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
ZERO SIX AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
CORPORATION. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
ONE SIXTY WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY REPENTANT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON YOUR AMENDMENTS THAT SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY SIXTY OR TECHNICAL. TO
HELP ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS
RAISED BY THE LEAGUE OF CITIES.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OBJECTION
TO A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL HOSE OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. ONE
TWENTY SIX. AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY WITH A
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOW
ASSEMBLY FALOON ARE A ON YOUR
MEN YOU THINK I DON'T KNOW I'M
DOING. THANK YOU MADAM I RISE TO
THE PER OF A MAN- TO AB EIGHT
NINETY. THEY ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING IN A NEIGHBORS. ASK
YOUR A- THANK YOU SEEING AND
HEARING NO OBJECTION TO TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSING. THE ICE IT THE
IN ARE DOT THE BILL IS OUT PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE AB TWENTY. THREE
FIFTY SIX. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ
AND OTHERS AND I RELATING TO
CRIMES. I REMEMBER AFTER YOU GET
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE FOR THE
SIX WOULD ALLOW COURTS TO
AGGREGATE THEFT COUNTS AS IF THE
STAFF WAS ARRANGED IN CONCERT.
MANY RETAILERS THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING FLASH MOBS EVENTS
WORD INDIVIDUALS PUT TOGETHER TO
DESCEND ON STORES AS A GROUP AND
STILL MERCHANDISE. UNDER
EXISTING LAW FLASH FROM
PARTICIPANTS WHO ORGANIZED THE
STORE PROPERTY AND EACH STILL
LESS THAN NINE FIFTY MAY ONLY BE
CHARGED WITH PETTY THEFT HOWEVER
THE NET LOSS TO THE RETAILER IS
OFTEN THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
THE COORDINATED NATURE OF THE
CRIME. THIS BILL WOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT INDIVIDUALS ACCORDING TO
THEFT DO NOT OPERATE ALONE AND
THEIR AGGREGATED ACTIONS OFTEN
PASSED THE THRESHOLD FOR GRANT
F. R. SPEC YES RIVAL. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GUESS. C. AND
HEARING AT NO FOR DEBATE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU ALL THE BIG
HAVING SEIZE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE. THOSE
VOTE DESIGNED TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES. HIGHS FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB
NINETEEN NO ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IN THIS AREA THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
SYRIAN AND APPLICANTS ADULTERY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE IN YOUR
RECOGNIZING WOULD ASK THE
SPEAKER A AB NINETEEN OH ONE
REQUIRES DOG TRAINERS TO
DISCLOSE BASIC INFORMATION IN
WRITING TO A DOG OWNERS
PURCHASING THEIR SERVICES BEFORE
A TRANSACTION IS COMPLETED WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. SEEING AND
HEARING FURTHER DEBATE. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE VOTES WHERE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE M
OSE VOTED IS ACTIVE VOTES.
I WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES. IS FORTY SEVEN NO
SEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES. ON TO
THE- OKAY JUST. WE'LL MOVE ON
NOW TO AYE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
NINE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLOW THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BLL
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOGIN ACCOLADE
TO ONLINE CONTENT. SO
RECOGNIZING YOUR AS A VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE NINE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF CYBER
BULLYING INCREASING SAFEGUARDS
TO PROTECT YOUNG INDIVIDUALS
FROM HARM- IT'S ALSO FITTING
THAT WE'RE RECOGNIZING STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH WEEK NEXT WEEK.
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN HELP
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THIS IS
REACHED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SEE AND HEARING NO FURTHER
TO I'M ITEM. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. RIGHT TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE FOLKS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTED DOES. IS FORTY
NINE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
SIXTEEN EIGHT MEMBER LEAVE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE AND ACCORDING TO
TRANSPORTATION. THANK EARLY
THANK YOU SAMANTHA MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY IS MEANT TO
ADDRESS CHAPARRAL ISSUES MY BILL
THE SIGNED INTO LAW LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A CONSENT BOTH THE
COMMITTEES RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
OF. SEEING IN. EIGHT THE CARD
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. RIGHT TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. I FIFTY THREE A
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES. I FIFTY FIVE NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES. WE'LL MOVE
ON NOW TO FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
AB TWENTY FOUR OH SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IDEA CURRY THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
OH SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS A
MAPPING TO BUSINESS. ELEVEN YOUR
RECORD AT YOUR DESK GOOD MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY
HOURS SIX TWO LIMIT CHARGED TO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES ALSO KNOWN
AS DETENTION AND DEMURRAGE BY
INTERMODAL MARINE EQUIPMENT
PROVIDERS WHEN THE CAUSES
OUTSIDE THE CONTROL OF THE
SHIPPER INDOOR TRUCKER ABUSIVE
DETENTION INTO PRACTICES WORSE
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS BY
MONETIZING DELAYS TO THE BENEFIT
OF THE EQUIPMENT PROVIDERS AT
THE COST OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS AB
TWENTY FOUR OH SIX RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND IS
SUPPORTED BY OVER SIXTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS COLLEAGUES SITE.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DELAY DEBATE
THE WILL OPEN ROLE. ALL THOSE
VOTE WHERE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE YOU DESIRE TO. ALL THOSE
VOTE ELKS. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WELL BEING ON TO FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT AB SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS THE
CLERK. ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
ACCORDING TO THE BERMAN A
QUALITY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
HE RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR DAD.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT SIMPLY BILL
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO WHICH WILL
HELP STREAMLINE THE CONSTRUCTION
AND REPAIR VITAL WATER WELLS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
SEEING IN HERE FURTHER DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE WILL YOU DESIRE TO.
ALL THOSE VOCAL DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES. I FIFTY THREE KNOWS
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES. WILL
MOVE ON TO IT FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
THREE OF US THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ABOUT US
AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
PEOPLE AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOOSE. HERE RECOGNIZED YOUR DESK
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT WOULD MAKE
CLIMATE CHANGE OF COURSE
REQUIREMENT. FOR GRADES ONE
THROUGH TWELVE SO THAT OUR
FUTURE LEADERS CAN GAIN THE
KNOWLEDGE NEED TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. AB NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE WOULD ENSURE THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION IS
TAUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS BY
REQUIRING REQUIRING THE
APPROPRIATE COURSE WERE TO BE
OFFERED TO STUDENTS NO LATER
THAN THE TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR SCHOOL YEAR. CALIFORNIA HAS
CERTAINLY MADE SOME PROGRESS ON
ADVANCING CLIMATE CHANGE
LITERACY. BUT THERE REMAINS MUCH
MORE WORK TO BE DONE TO TEACH
THESE TOPICS IN OUR SCHOOLS
SINCE THE STATE'S ATTEMPTS TO
TEACH ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
REMAIN OPTIONAL. YOU HAVE
ALREADY MOBILIZED AS KEY LEADERS
IN CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ACTIVISM BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEIR
GENERATION WILL HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES THE CHANGE
CLIMATE. AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
WILL EMPOWER STUDENTS TO FIND
CLIMATE CHANGE SOLUTIONS THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REQUEST IS DAVID DERECH. THANK
MADAM. MA'AM ARE STATE THIS
HISTORIC AND CONCERNING VERY
CONSCIOUS WE NOW HAVE A
DANGEROUS YEAR ROUND FIRE SEASON
. ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES WE'RE DEALING WITH
COSTAR ROSEN AN INCREASE IN
FREQUENTLY OF COASTAL FLOODING
EVENTS. THAT'S WHY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE BECAUSE WE NEED TO HAVE THE
NEXT GENERATION BE EDUCATED BUT
WHAT. TYPES OF CONSERVATION. GEN
EFFORTS WILL BE NEW PRESERVE
HELLO. VERY TOURISM A MAJOR
FINDINGS FOR MY DISTRICT AND
IT'S IMPERATIVE IT REMAINS THAT
WAY FOR YEARS TO COME. THE ONLY
WAY TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN IS FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND FUTURE LEADERS
LEARN ABOUT PROPER MITIGATION
INFORMATION FOR THESE REASONS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS DAVIES. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REQUEST WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. WITH THAT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO GO
. ALL THOSE VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTING THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE LOCAL CLOSER
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES. HIGHS
FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED AB NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE BY SOME
MEMBERS ALISON ACCORDING TO
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER FROM THE
PRISON SIMPLY BILL NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE
PURCHASING GENE SYNTHESIS
PRODUCTS FROM RESPONSIBLE
COMPANIES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE THE CLERK WILL.
OPEN ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTES. ALL THOSE VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE. AND TALLY THE
VOTES. IS FORTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA THE CLERK WILL READ
. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA IMMACULATE IN THE FORESTS
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAR YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN WOULD ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA POCKET FORCE
INITIATIVE A PROGRAM THAT WULD
HAVE TO AUTHORIZE KALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE GRANTS REPORT TO FORCE
A PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT ENTITIES.
A POCKET FORCES A SMALL PLOT OF
URBAN LAND THAT HAS BEEN DENSELY
PLANTED WITH NATIVE PLANT
SPECIES IT IS DESIGNED ACCORDING
TO THE MEAL MEDIA WALKIE
METHODIST OF TREE PLANTING THE
DIRECT GROWERS A STUDY IN EMILY
IN AREAS NATIVE BECAUSE- OVER
THE COURSE OF TWO THREE YEARS
THESE PLANS ARE GOING TO A SELF
SUSTAINING MANAGER FOREST. THEY
CAN OFFER A WIDE RANGE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
BENEFITS OF FOR EXAMPLE POCKET
FORCE CONSERVATIVES FROM PORT
PLAN ANIMAL SPECIES AND PROVIDE
HEALTHY GREEN SPACE. SPACES A
TENS OF MILLIONS URBAN
CALIFORNIANS THESE PROJECTS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SUCCESSFULLY PLANET
SUCH VERY PLACES BRAZIL INDIA
UNITED KINGDOM- AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AB TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN SERVES AS A MUCH NEEDED
BEACON FOR THE ACTUAL COMMUNITY
ORIENTED ENVIRONMENTALIST
MOVEMENT WILL INSURE THAT URBAN
COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
AND ENJOY THE MANY BENEFITS OF
NATURAL GREEN SPACES SPECT. THE
ASPIRIN I VOTE. C. AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR ALL. ALL THOSE VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL. ALL
THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
NICK.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI
THE- IS FORTY SIX NO SEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE ZERO NINE AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN BURGLARY. ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
ACCOLADE THE PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX
IS CODE CLEAN UP REQUESTED BY
THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY CURRENT VERSION OF
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. AND I
ABOUT. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE. TURKEY'S CHECK. LOCAL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES I SIXTEEN NO. ZERO
MEMBERS WE WOULD LIKE TO GO AND
ACTUALLY GO BACK TO RECOGNIZING
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA. JOINING US IN
THE GALLERY ARE MEMBERS OF THE
LICENSED PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
FOR MEXICO PILOT PROGRAM. PLEASE
WELCOME OUR GUESTS TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM AB AT ONE
ELEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO
CALDERON CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC WILL SECOND
EDUCATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO TWELVE
DOUBLES A WELLNESS VENDING
MACHINE PILOT PROGRAM AT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE TO
ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE SUFFICIENT
ACCESS. TO HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PRODUCTS THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ALLOW STUDENTS TO ACCESS
DISCOUNTED OVER THE COUNTER
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PRODUCTS
OUTSIDE PHARMACY HOURS AND
WITHOUT NEEDING TO LEAVE THEIR
CAMPUS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE M
TE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE.GLOBAL CLOSER ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
-
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
MY FONG THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIKE FONG AFRO THE STATE LAW. I
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND-
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE
ONE SEVEN DOES TWO THINGS
RELATED TO WEBSITE ACCESSIBILITY
FIRST IT WOULD REQUIRE AN
ATTORNEY INVOLVED IN WEBSITE
ACCESSIBILITY LITIGATION TO
REPORT INFORMATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
DISABILITY ACCESS. CERTAINLY
WOULD REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
PREPARE EDUCATION INFORMATION ON
WEBSITE ACCESSIBILITY STANDARDS
WEBSITE ACCESSIBILITY HAS BECOME
AN INCREASINGLY PREVALENT LEGAL
ISSUE MORE SPECIFICALLY LAWSUITS
INVOLVING AND ACCESSIBLE
WEBSITES A VIOLATION OF CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY COMMON. WE LIKE.
REQUEST INFORMATION TO GIVES A
CLEAR SENSE AS TO HOW MUCH MORE
COMMONSENSE THESE LAWSUITS ARE
BECOMING. AB TWO NINE ONE SEVEN
WILL LEAD TO THE COLLECTION OF
INFORMATION THAT WOULD GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH LAWSUIT.
INVOLVING WEBSITE EXCESSIVELY.
HAS BECOME AS WELL AS OUR
OUTCOMES FURTHER TO ASSIST
BUSINESSES AND AVOIDING IN
LITIGATION A. B. TWO NINE ONE
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION ON DISABILITY ACCESS
TO THE VALVE EDUCATION
INFORMATION. FOR BUSINESSES TO
ENSURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
OBLIGATIONS REGARDING DISABILITY
ACCESS TO THE WEBSITE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ASSEMBLY GUIDING YOU YOUR REC. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS JUST A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR IF I MAY
. YOU'RE A THANK YOU. EXISTING
ON A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL I KNOW
I NEW TO THE ASSEMBLY VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET THINGS MOVING-
IN FACT YOU'RE IN LOS ANGELES
ALL THE TIME EVERYWHERE IN FACT
YOU MAY BE IN LOS ANGELES RIGHT
NOW AT AN EVENT I'M CURIOUS-
SECTION TWENTY FOUR POINT SEVEN
AB ON YOUR BILL IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT ON
THAT TO FURTHER CLARIFY. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS SUMMER-
COMMITTEE FOR THAT WONDERFUL
QUESTION ALL INTERESTED IN MY
CLOSING AND IT REALLY. AND THE
ALL YOUR MEDICINE. C. AND
HEARING NO FOR DEBATE. ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL THOSE VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE AND THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. I SIXTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN H. R. ONE OH ONE JONES
SAWYER THE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE A ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
RELATIVE TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
EUROPEAN NICE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE ON ONE WITH
CALLS AND MORE ECOBILL FOR
CALIFORNIA. TO COUNTLESS ROUTE
THE STATE ARE NEARING OR HAVE
COMPLETED THE SCHOOL YEAR WITH
GRADES THAT UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT
REFLECT THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF
COURSE MATERIAL INSTEAD THEIR
GRADES REPRESENT THEIR ABILITY
TO KEEP UP WITH THE CLASS SAID
SCHEDULE. THE COSBY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC EXACERBATED MANY
INEQUITIES IN OUR SOCIETY AND
BECOMES CLEAR THAT WE ARE WE AS
A STATE MUST REEVALUATE. SYSTEMS
DURALENS OF EQUITY AND INCLUSION
AS PART OF EFFORTS SOME
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
BEGUN TO SCRUTINIZE THE GRADING
POLICIES AND IMPLEMENT
COMMONSENSE CHANGES REGION
RESEARCHER GRADING METHODS HAVE
FOUND CLEAR DEFICIENCIES IN OUR
TRADITIONAL BEHAVIOR ORIENTED
APPROACH INCLUDING POTENTIALLY
STIFLING RISK TAKING SKILLS AND
LLOWING TRUST BETWEEN TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS. THIS TRADITIONAL
GRADING APPROACH IS LESS LIKELY
TO ACCURATELY REPRESENT A
STUDENTS UNDERSTANDING OF COURSE
MATERIAL IS DEAD IT D. MOTIVATES
AND DIS EMPOWERS OUR YOUNG
LEARNERS FOR THAT REASON HR ONE
ONE URGES SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
ADOPT MORE EQUITABLE MASTERY
GRADING PRACTICES AN EXPANSE
PORT SYSTEMS IN RESPONSE THE
COVERT NINETEEN. THROUGH MASTERY
BASED GRADING SCHOOLS CAN ASSIGN
GRADES THAT REFLECT STUDENTS
ACHIEVEMENT OF CLEARLY SET
LEARNING GOALS AND ALLOW FOR
FLEXIBLE. TO COLLECT EVIDENCE OF
LEARNING MORE STEP MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS APPROACH ALLOWS
FOR MULTIPLE STEP THEIR
INTERVENTION BEFORE'S ASSIGNING
A FAILING GRADE TO A STUDENT
THESE PRICES WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN TRANSFORMING OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM TO CONSIDER
STUDENTS FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS
ENSURE INSTRUCTIONS ISN'T
TAILORED TO FIT THEIR NEEDS AND
PROVIDE AS MUCH SUPPORT AS
POSSIBLE FOR THEM TO SUCCEED.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA MUST EMBRACE
POLICY THEY GIVE OUR STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCE AND OPPORTUNITIES
SUCCEED I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU JOHN
SAWYER WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST
REAL TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
YES. MISTER JONES SAWYER HAS
ASKED FOR THE ROLE TO BE OPENED
FOR CO AUTHORS AND ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE FOR. MEMBERS FOR CALL
AUTHORS ALL THOSE VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE
WHO DESIGNED TO VOTE. MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CALL AUTHORS. ALL
THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL NOW
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'LL
MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
TWO THREE OF US THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
THIRTY TWO BY. LUIS WE'VE US AND
OTHERS THAT I PUT IN THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES. GOOD THIS YOUR
RECOGNIZED GOOD MORNING MADAMS
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
PROHIBIT SEABED MINING AND STATE
COASTAL WATERS DUE TO THE HIGH
RISK OF DAMAGE AND DISRUPTION TO
OUR OCEAN MARINE HABITAT AND
STATE'S ECONOMY THIS BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS SUPPORTED BY BUSINESS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
ALONG WITH THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IPHONE. THANK YOU MYSTERY OF
US. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. LOCAL CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES. I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ALL REMAINING ITEMS SHALL BE
PASSED IN A CHANGED MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON. TO CONSENT
CALENDAR SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS
ON TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEMS ONE EIGHTY FOUR TO ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. BEFORE WE VOTES.
WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP FILE ITEMS
ONE EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN ON CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOLUTION ONE FOURTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER WHEN RELATIVE TO OUR
YARD DAY. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONCE OF THE NINE VICE
ROLLED ON A ROAD TRIP TO SUIT
MENTAL HEALTH WEEK SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
RELATIVE TO GIRLS ON THE RUN
GREATER SACRAMENTO DAY AND HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAPER RELATIVE TO
ISRAELI AMERICANS. THE CLERK THE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR. LUCIEN ALL
MEMBERS DESIRE TO GO ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE MEMBERS IF
YOU WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME AS A
CO AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTIONS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE VOTE
NOW. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY THREE CO
AUTHORS. MOVING ON NOW TO VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. FILE
ITEMS. ONE FORTY TWO TO ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. DOES ANY MEMBER
WHICH TO REMOVE ANY ADDITIONAL
ITEMS FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE OH EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AND ACTUALLY
THE PEOPLE SERVICES. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHAT HE DESIRED TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTES. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ASSEMBLY TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN I FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN
NINETEEN. FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SO
MEMBERS SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
URGENCY FIFTY EIGHT ZERO. ON THE
URGENCY I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE WILSHIRE C.
I. FIFTY EIGHT ON THOSE KNOWS ON
THE URGENCY I FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN FORTY SIX. I FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SYMBOL SEVENTEEN
FIFTEEN I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT NO. SIMPLE SEVENTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT WITH URGENCY I FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS ON THE URGENCY FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE SO
MEMBERS FIFTY NINE. FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SUM APPROACH EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS THERE ARE SOME ABILITY
FONG I EIGHT KNOWS SUM EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FOR I FIFTY EIGHT ZERO
APRIL NINETEENTH WITH URGENCY I
FIFTY KNOWS THEY'RE ON THE EDGE
. I FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS YOUR ON
THE MEASURE ASSEMBLY NINETEEN
THREE I EIGHT NO ZERO REMAIN
EIGHTY NINE I FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SUM BILL TWO THIRTY. I
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY EIGHT I EIGHT NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE ONE OH FIVE I FIFTY
NO ZERO APPROACH ONE TWO I SEE
EIGHT KNOWS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE SEVEN I FIFTY
ZERO SUM TWENTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SUM IT WILL
TWO TWO I EIGHT KNOWS THERE ARE
SOME TWENTY THREE TWENTY. FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
WITH THE REDUCING I FIFTY KNOWS
THERE ON THE- URGENCY I SPEAK
EIGHT KNOWS ON THE MEASURE SOME
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY. I FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY TWO I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SOMETHING TO FOR TWENTY FOUR TWO
I FIFTY EIGHT ZERO PEOPLE.
TWENTY SIX THREE. FIFTY EIGHT.
EIGHTY THREE I FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY TWO I FIFTY
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FOURTEEN. I FIFTY
EIGHT NOCERA'S IMMIGRANT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY NINE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SUM OCCUR
RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION
NINETY NINE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
ANDERSON COOPER TWENTY NINE
SIXTY NINE. FIFTY EIGHT ZERO.
MEMBERS MY ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
WE HAVE ONE COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SIX. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT. I
WOULD LIKE TO CORRECT MY VOTE ON
THE- AB SIXTEEN FORTY TWO I.
ABLE TO DO THAT STILL. WE PLEASE
EIGHT SO RECOGNIZE SO NOTED.
FROM ON HIGH TO A NOT VOTING.
NOT KNOWING. SO NOTED THE GLOBAL
NETWORK. SIX SIXTEEN FORTY TWO-
WE WILL TAKE CARE OF THIS
APARTMENT. IN THE AT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA ARE YOU. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WHO ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR OR
TAKE YOUR SEATS. MISTER KALRA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I JOIN WITH-
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE FROM OTHER
CALLING FROM SAN JOSE- TO RICE'S
DURING THE MEMORY HONOR OF
NORMAN YOSHIDA MINETA NORMA'S
NOTICE NORM TO EVERYONE THAT
KNEW HIM WHO PASSED AWAY THIS
TUESDAY MAY THIRD. BORN IN SAN
JOSE ON NOVEMBER TWELFTH
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE NORMAN
MINETA WAS A TRAILBLAZER FOR
COUNTLESS ASIAN AMERICANS IN
POLITICS AND PUBLIC SERVICE
INCLUDING PRETTY MUCH EVERY. A
PAST MEMBER ON THIS FLOOR. HE
BEGAN HIS POLITICAL LIFE IN SAN
JOSE HAS THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN MAYOR OF A MAJOR CITY
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. I WAS
LATER ELECTED TO CONGRESS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WE FOUNDED
THE CONGRESSIONAL ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN CAUCUS. AND SERVED TEN
YEARS REPRESENTING MUCH OF MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. THROUGHOUT
HIS CAREER. ANOTHER DISCOVERED A
PASSION FOR TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES. WHICH GROUP CULMINATED
IN BEING APPOINTED AS THE FIRST
JAPANESE JAPANESE AMERICAN
CABINET MEMBER AS COMMERCE
SECRETARY IN THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION AND AS A
TESTAMENT TO HIS DEVOTION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE CONTINUE TO SERVE
AS TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY
UNDER THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
FROM 200-012-0006 IS THE ONLY
DEMOCRAT IN THAT CABINET. ON
NINE ELEVEN SECRETARY MINETA
MADE THE UNPRECEDENTED ORDER TO
GROUND ALL. FOUR THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT PLANES IN
US AIRSPACE. IN LESS THAN TWO
AND A HALF HOURS EVERY PLANE. IN
THE COUNTRY. IT LANDED. AND
HEARING THAT STORY FROM HIM
PERSONALLY IS AS RIVETING.
SECRETARY MINETA HEADED THE
EFFORT TO START A NEW AGENCY THE
TRANSPORTATION SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED A LITTLE OVER TWO
MONTHS AFTER NINE ELEVEN. TO
HONOR HIS SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY AND RECOGNIZES GREAT
CAREER THE SOUNDS A CITY COUNCIL
VOTED TO RENAME THE CITY'S
AIRPORT AFTER HIM THE TWO
THOUSAND ONE SO NOW WHEN YOU
FIND A SAN JOSE SOME OF YOU MAY
HAVE WONDERED. MINETA YOU KNOW
THE STORY. THE LIFE AND LEGACY
IN NORMAN AT AS REMARKABLE
AMERICAN STORY THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO INSPIRE GENERATIONS
TO COME. FOR HE BELIEVED IN THE
AMERICAN DREAM. I WAS THE
EPITOME OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
EVEN THOUGH AS A CHILD AMERICA
CAN NEVER DREAM. OF THE HALLS OF
POWER HE WOULD CLIMB TO. AT TEN
YEARS OLD WEARING A BOY SCOUT
UNIFORM AND HOLDING ON TO A
MINUTE AND A BASEBALL BAT. HE
AND HIS FAMILY. BIRBAL FORCED
ONTO A TRAIN AND TAKEN AWAY FROM
SAN JOSE. TO WYOMING TO INTERMIX. WE WILL TAKE IT ON THE TRAIN
THEY TOOK THE BASEBALL BAT AWAY
SAYING IT WAS A DANGEROUS WEAPON.HE WOULD LATER BECOMEONE OF
THE STRONGEST ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF POSSIBLY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND JAPANESE
AMERICANS. WHO WERE FORCED INTO
INTERNMENT CAMPS DURING WORLD
WAR TWO. HE LED CONGRESS TO PASS
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH LED
TO A FORMAL APOLOGIES APOLOGIES
FOR THE US GOVERNMENT AND
REPARATIONS FOR THOSE. WHO
SUFFERED. WHEN MR MCNAMARA
SERVED IN CONGRESS THERE WAS A
MAN FROM LOS ANGELES. CENTUM YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE BASEBALL BAT
STORIES SENTIMENTAL CAN GIFT.
TRANSAT THAT TOKEN GIFT WAS
ABOUT THAT IT BELONGED TO HALL
OF FAMER HANK AARON- IT WAS
WORTH OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHICH YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ARE GIVEN AS THEY DO IN CONGRESS
TO FIFTY SO- HE HAD TO- WE
RETURNED THE BAT BACK TO ITS
CENTER. AND HE'S HE'S FAMOUSLY
KNOWN FOR SAYING THE DAM
GOVERNMENT'S TAKEN MY BAD AGAIN
. YOU KNOW I HAD THE GREAT
FORTUNE AND HONOR TO KNOW NORM-
AND HAD THE PRIVILEGE. TO
REPRESENT THE CITY A MODE WHERE
IT ALL BEGAN FOR HIM BUT
CERTAINLY DIDN'T AND- HE IT WAS
AN EXTRAORDINARY PERSON THAT WAS
SO GENTLE AND IT WAS A LINE AT
THE SAME TIME- JUST AB A FIERCE
ADVOCATE. ON BEHALF OF CIVIL
RIGHTS AND POLICY WONK THAN YOU
TRANSPORTATION AND WE HAVE THE
MINETA TRANSPORTATION INSTITUTE
NOW WHICH IS FOREVER HIS LEGACY.
HE HE KNEW THE ISSUES A
TRANSPORTATION BETTER THAN
ANYONE I KNOW AND I'VE EVER
KNOWN- AND MOST OF ALL HE WAS
JUST A GREAT FRIEND AND SOMEONE
THAT. ALWAYS SUPPORTED US
ESPECIALLY US YOUNG ONES THAT
WE'RE COMING UP BEHIND THEM HE
HE- IT'S NOT EVEN ABOUT
FORGETTING ABOUT WHERE HE CAME
FROM HE NEVER LEFT WHERE HECAME
FROM. AND- HE'LL BE MISSED
DEARLY- ONE OF SENATE
CONDOLENCES. TO HIS WIFE DANNY
AND HIS CHILDREN WHO ARE HE'S
ALSO SO VERY PROUD OF. I WAS
ALWAYS SO PROUD OF THEM. AND
IT'S JUST A GREAT PRIVILEGE TO
BE ABLE TO EVEN SAY A FEW WORDS
IN HIS HONOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES I ALSO
JOINED- MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
JOSE AND RECOGNIZING THE
INCREDIBLE CONTRIBUTIONS. OF OUR
VERY OWN NORMAN MINETA. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SENATE SAY
CONTINUES THE LEGACY OF
SECRETARY MINETA SERVING IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE. AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THREE MEMBERS
OF THIS ASSEMBLY BODY REPRESENTS
SAN JOSE CURRENTLY OF ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER DESCENT. MUCH
OF A STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF
SECRETARY MINETA. AND I HAVE THE
HONOR TO VISIT. SECRETARY MINETA
JUST IN DECEMBER TO CELEBRATE
HIS NINETIETH BIRTHDAY. AND WHEN
I SAID TO HIM HAPPY NINETIETH
BIRTHDAY HE SAID THANK YOU MY I.
Q. IS THE SAME NUMBER AS MY AGE
AND JOKING FASHION. BUT THE
SPIRIT OF THE GENERATION THAT HE
CAME FROM WAS THAT OF
PARTNERSHIP OVER PARTISANSHIP.
AND HIS BEST FRIEND WAS THAT OF
REPUBLICAN SENATOR. BUT HE
CONTINUES. THE WORK HERE IN THIS
BODY AND THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES. AND THAT IN THAT REGARD
WE THANK HIS FAMILY FOR ALLOWING
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO BORROW HIM
AS A PUBLIC SERVANT HE IS OUR
ICON. AND LET US BE REMINDED NOW
TO SPECIFICALLY THE MEMBERS OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AS WE
CELEBRATE AND RECOGNIZE THE
MONTH OF MAY AS ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE BY. THE
INCREDIBLE WORK AN OBLIGATION
THAT WE HAVE. HERE IN THIS
INSTITUTION. FINALLY IF I COULD
JUST SHARE A CONVERSATION I HAD
WITH SECRETARY MINETA WHEN I WAS
WITH HIM IN DECEMBER WHICH WAS I
ASKED HIM. UNCLE NORM BUT I
WOULD CALL HIM UNCLE NORM. WHAT
DO WE DO TO STOP ASIAN HATE. AND
HIS RESPONSE WAS. IT'S UP TO
YOUR GENERATION NOW. THE PRESENT
I'VE DONE MY PART AND I KNOW
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE. SO AGAIN
LET US BE REMINDED BY THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR GREAT
STATESMAN AND EMBODYING AND
REPLICATING THIS STATESMANSHIP
THAT WE MUST ALL DEMONSTRATE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY WITH THAT I SEND
OUR CONDOLENCES AND REGARDS THE
INCREDIBLE MINETA FAMILY. THANK
YOU MR LOW MISTER MOORE RECCA.
THANK YOU VERY MATTER SPEAKER
FOR LET ME A FEW WORDS.
REGARDING SOME THAT WAS SO
BELOVED- IN THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. I FIRST HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET NORMAN AT A- IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SHORTLY AFTER.
PRESIDENT REAGAN SIGNED THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT. WHICH
GRANTED I'LL BE HALF OF THE
NATION AN APOLOGY AND
REPARATIONS. TWO JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE INCARCERATED IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS DURING WORLD
WAR TWO. NORM OR AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE SILICON VALLEY-
INDICATED. UNCLE NORM TO THOSE
WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO KNOW
HIM. WAS BELOVED. HE WAS SO DOWN
TO EARTH HE EVEN AFTER.
ACHIEVING THIS MONUMENTAL
HISTORIC LEGISLATION HR FOUR
FOUR TWO NAMED AFTER THE
LEGENDARY WORLD WAR TWO ALL
JAPANESE AMERICAN BATTALION.
THAT LED TO THE APOLOGY AND
REPARATIONS FOR JAPANESE
AMERICANS. UNCLE NORMAL NEVER
FAIL TO SHOW UP. AND JAPANESE
AMERICAN EVENTS THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN CITIZENS LEAGUE
NATIONAL CONVENTIONS JAPANESE
AMERICAN NATIONAL MUSEUM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY. UNCLE NORM WAS
ALWAYS THERE. HE WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED NOT ONLY AS A GIANT.
IN ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDER
POLITICS. BUT ALSO SOMEONE WHO
REALLY NEVER FORGOT WHERE HE
CAME FROM. AS A DOWN TO EARTH
AND KIND. AND BELOVED. MEMBER
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME JOIN
THIS ADJOURN IN MEMORY. FOR OUR
BELOVED NORMAN AT A- THANK YOU
MR MARTUCCI MR HOLDEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE AND REQUEST THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
MICHAEL A. WILL MARK SENIOR.
SURROUNDED BY HIS ADORING FAMILY
MICHELANGELO WHO WILL MARK
SENIOR BORN FEBRUARY NINTH
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE. HE'S
FULLY TRANSITIONED TO HIS
HEAVENLY HOME ON APRIL FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AFTER A HARD
FOUGHT BATTLE WITH GASTRIC
CANCER. MIKE WAS BORN IN LIVE
NEW ORLEANS LOUISIANA LEARNING
CONSTRUCTION AND SPORTS SKILLS
BEFORE HIS ST AUGUSTINE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION IN NINETEEN
FIFTY. AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR HE
MARRIED THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
GRAN WHO ME NEW SENSE IS KNOWN.
IS TWELVE YEARS. AND BY THE AGE
OF TWENTY TWO HAD FOUR CHILDREN.
BY THAT SAME AGE HE GRADUATED
FROM EXIT OF YOUR UNIVERSITY IN
LOUISIANA AND PLAYED MULTIPLE
YEARS OF NEGRO LEAGUE AND
PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL WHILE THE
FAMILY REMAINED IN THE NEW
ORLEANS. ALGIERS DISTRICT. WELL
THIS FAMILY WAS ALWAYS FIRST
BASEBALL WAS NEVER ABSENT IN
MICHAEL'S LIFE. AFTER HIS TIME
IN PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL HE
PLAYED SEMI PRO AND MUNICIPAL
LEAGUES IN HIS LATE FORTIES
COACHES SIGNS AND SOME GRANDSONS
AT MULTIPLE LEVELS EMPIRE.
BOTTOM HIRING WATCH THEM ALL
FROM LITTLE LEAGUE TO WORLD
SERIES ON TELEVISION. WAS A
REGULAR DODGER STADIUM IN LATE
LED MANY CONVERSATIONS AND TOLD
JOKES OF HIS BASEBALL EXPORTS.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT HIS
LOVE OF BASEBALL WAS A MAJOR
COMPONENT OF HIS LIFE STORY AND
I'M PROUD TO HONOR THAT BY
TELLING HIS STORY. MICHAEL WAS
UNIVERSALLY KNOWN FOR HIS GREAT
SMILE EXCITING DANCE MOVES
ENGAGING DEMEANOR COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP. AND LOVING LASTING
NURTURING CONNECTIONS WITH ALL
WHOM. HE CAME IN CONTACT.
MICHAEL IS SURVIVED BY HIS
LOVING FAMILY FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMBER OF A TRUE PASADENA IN A
COMMUNITY PILLAR MICHAEL A
HALLMARK. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
MYSTERY B. O. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY I'M NOT A JOINING IN THE
MEMORY OF AN ELECTED OFFICIAL A
COMMUNITY DEAR LEADER OR A CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER. I'M ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY OF A WOMAN THAT COULD BE
OUR MOTHER OR GRANDMOTHER.
SLAVIA FROM THE YOUNG WAS BORN
IN ZACATECAS MEXICO. BUT AT THE
AGE OF TWO YEARS OLD HER MOTHER
AND BABY SISTER DIED DURING
CHILDBIRTH. FLOPPY I WOULD NEVER
KNOW THE LOVE OF A MOTHER BUT
WAS RECOGNIZED AS THE MOTHER OF
THE YEAR IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. BY RADIO BILLING WITHOUT
THE APPEALING WAY IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA. BLOB BLOB YOU CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY WITH HER HUSBAND
FELIX IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
WITH ELEVEN OF HER OF THEIR
CHILDREN. AND NOTHING BUT THEIR
DREAMS OR A BETTER TOMORROW.
FLABBY AND HER HUSBAND FELIX
WORKED IN THE FIELDS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WALLY REYES THEIR
TWELVE CHILDREN AND ALWAYS
FINDING THE TIME TO ATTEND
SUNDAY MASS. WHERE THEIR SONS
WERE ALTAR BOYS AND THE
DAUGHTERS PARTICIPATED IN THE
READINGS. THEIR CHILDREN PLAYED
SPORTS IN SCHOOL PLAYED MUSICAL
INSTRUMENTS AND UNDERSTOOD THE
VALUE OF HARD WORK. AND
DEDICATION THROUGH THEIR PARENTS
EXAMPLE. FELIX AND SLAVIA FOUND
A PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR CHILDREN
ACHIEVING A FAMILY DREAM. FLOPPY
ANY SUCCESS BUT SHE ALSO
BELIEVED LOS AS SHE GAVE BIRTH
TO FULL FOURTEEN CHILDREN WITH
TO DYING AS TODDLERS AND THEN
SUFFERING A LOSS A MOTHER SHOULD
NEVER INDOOR. WHEN HER EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER MARTHA WAS
MURDERED AND HER FRESHMAN YEAR
AT FRESNO STATE. A PIECE OF FIVE
LED THE AT AT. A PIECE OF FLAT
FLAP YET DIED WITH MARTHA.
LOSING HER THIRD CHILD BROKE HER
SPIRIT. HOWEVER SHE PERSISTED
AND THROUGH HER FAITH IN GOD SHE
FOUND THE STRENGTH TO CONTINUE.
TO BE THE MATRIARCH OF HER
FAMILY. AFTER HER HUSBAND FELIX
PASSED AWAY IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE. SLAVIA RECENTLY BECAME A
HOMEOWNER WHEN SHE FINISHED
PAYING HER MORTGAGE REAL
REALIZING HER AMERICAN DREAM.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SLAVIA WHY SHE
LEFT MEXICO SHE DID WHAT SHE
WOULD ALWAYS SAY I WANTED MORE
FOR MY CHILDREN. LOBBYIST
CHILDREN ATTENDED AND GRADUATED
FROM COLLEGE THEY HAVE GROWN UP
TO BE SOCIAL WORKERS NONPROFIT
ADVOCATES HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
EDUCATORS COMMUNITY ADVOCATES.
BUSINESS OWNERS UNION MEMBERS
HOMEOWNERS VOTERS AND HER CHART
THIRTEENTHS CHILD. IS MY CHIEF
OF STAFF MANY SANTIAGO. SLAVIA
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY WITH HER
ELEVEN CHILDREN BY HER SIDE.
SLAVIA SANTIAGO LEAVES A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE OF HER CHILDREN
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF THEM HAVE ATTENDED THE
BEST UNIVERSITIES IN OUR GOLDEN
STATE ARE AND ARE NOW
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHERS POLICE
OFFICERS COMMUNITY LEADERS
SOCIAL WORKERS AND EDUCATORS.
SHE LEAVES CALIFORNIA WITH THE
BEST OF WHAT SHE HAD TO OFFER
AND WITH A BRIGHT TOMORROW
BRIGHTER TOMORROW. MAY SHE REST
IN POWER AND SLEEP WITH THE
ANGELS AND BY THIS CONCEPTS
SONORA DR YES ON THE YOUNG.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. OUR REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MOVING ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE
SESSION. EDGELL IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY MAY SIXTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY MAY NINTH FLOOR SESSION
WILL BEGIN AT ONE PM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PICKED
PASTORS CHAINED. ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. THIS BOERNER HORVATH SO
MOVES MISTER BENNETT SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY MAY NINTH AT ONE PM.
BOERNER HORVATH REMEMBER. SOUNDS
RIGHT AT. YOUR SYSTEM SHOULD BE. VOTE CHANGE BOERNER HORVATH AB
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO FROM I TO NOT
VOTING. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN FORTY TWO- IT'S
ABOUT VOTING. MODE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AB
TWENTY FOUR ZERO FOUR FROM ALL
RIGHT TO NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ SENATE
BILL TWENTY FOUR OH FOUR I DO
NOT VOTING. THE BILL CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEVE BENNETT.
AB SIXTEEN FORTY TWO FOR MY TO
NOT VOTING. CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FORTY TWO I TO NOT
VOTING.